Today, we’re getting scary. Scientifically
scary. When a fear becomes so severe that
it might get in the way of you living your
normal life, it becomes known as a phobia.
We’d wager to say that almost everyone watching
this video suffers from at least one of them,
and given we’ll be covering a staggering 28
phobias today, there’s a good chance that,
statistically, one of them is yours. But
we’re SCP Explained, not Phobias Explained,
so naturally, we’re going to be putting our
own spin on the concept of debilitating terror.
At the time of this video’s
recording, there are well over
6000 anomalies documented by the SCP
Foundation. Some are cute and adorable.
Some are funny. Some are badass. But most of them
are pants-soilingly terrifying. That’s why today,
we’re running down our big list of twenty-eight
soul-shattering phobias, and giving you the
perfect anomaly for each one. It’s gonna get scary
out here, so please, don’t say we didn’t warn you!
First, we’ve got Agoraphobia: The fear
of open spaces. People with this phobia
often avoid leaving the home, fearing that
they’ll have a panic attack in a wide open,
unfamiliar space. This is precisely why anyone
suffering from Agoraphobia would hate to have
a run-in with SCP-093, the Red Sea Object. When
placed against a mirror, this unassuming little
talisman can transport you to a nightmarish world
of wide, desolate deserts populated by craggy,
faceless giants out for your blood. With
nowhere safe to seclude yourself away,
SCP-093’s nightmarish dimension would
be an Agoraphobe’s living nightmare.
Then there’s Acrophobia: The fear of
heights. This is an incredibly common one,
and if being high up enough has ever
induced vertigo and made your legs
turn to jello beneath you, then
you can probably relate. But hey,
simply don’t go anywhere high up, right? Nice
and easy. Except SCP-3007, a deadly infohazard,
has the terrifying ability to bring those
heights to you. If you’re infected by SCP-3007,
you’ll have ultra-immersive hallucinations of
yourself teetering on the huge and impossibly
high-up walkways of a city full of silver spires.
And if this makes you dizzy, remember, it’s not
just a dream. If you fall from a great height
in your hallucination, you’ll die in real life.
But maybe you’d take being at the top
of the tower over having to deal with
anything that has eight legs. That is, if you
have Arachnophobia: The fear of spiders. This
one is self-explanatory, some people are
just debilitatingly terrified of spiders,
and they likely think about it a lot. You might
even say they have Intrusive Arachnid Thoughts,
like SCP-632, an anomaly that’s
likely to scare an arachnophobe
to death - Literally. If you see a tiny pink
spider with a strange pattern on its back,
it may already be over for you, as the horrors of
SCP-632 flood your mind with thoughts of spiders,
as your brain matter literally transforms into
a vast, skittering colony of the little beasts.
Maybe that last anomaly has you wanting
to just get up and fly away. Or maybe you
suffer from Pteromerhanophobia:
The fear of flying. Of course,
it’s nothing to be ashamed of. Unless you’re
enough of a baller to have a private jet,
you probably agree with everyone else
that flying absolutely sucks. Especially
if the flight you’re taking is SCP-787. This
cursed plane is filled with 515 human corpses,
perfectly illustrating what you fear will
happen to you on that plane. But it’s also
the site of a wide variety of terrifying
anomalous happenings, from violent sounds
to nightmarish figures roaming the cabin. And
who thought flying could possibly get any worse?
Next, we’re going to box you in a little, which
will absolutely terrify you if you suffer from
Claustrophobia: The fear of enclosed spaces. If
people with claustrophobia are confined or locked
up, they’re likely to experience a full-blown
panic attack. That’s why they’d utterly despise
SCP-1562, also known as the Carnivorous
Slide. This seemingly ordinary tube slide
will cause its victims to be teleported
to a mysterious place in total darkness,
so cramped that they can barely move, lodged
into place by mysterious items in the tight
tunnel around them. And if that wasn’t scary
enough, you’re not alone in this terrible,
claustrophobic place either. You don’t
want to know what happens after that.
But maybe it’s not the confinement
that scares you in that scenario,
but the lack of light. If that’s the case, you
may have Nyctophobia: The fear of the dark. And
if you do suffer from Nyctophobia, then
you’d absolutely hate to be stuck in SCP-087,
the Staircase. This place is filled with
a kind of darkness so oppressive that it
doesn’t follow the laws of physics - No
matter how powerful a light you bring in,
it cannot penetrate the haze. As you descend
deeper into the Staircase, you’ll find that
your sense of dread will only increase, as you
begin to hear a child crying far below. If you’re
foolish enough to keep going, you may end up face
to face with a certain pale, featureless face.
Though maybe that entity didn’t have nearly
enough legs to scare you. Perhaps you suffer
from Entomophobia: The fear of insects. There are
honestly more insectoid SCPs than we can even list
right now, but for the Entomophobia sufferers in
our audience, we think the scariest one out there
might be SCP-743, the Chocolate Fountain. Sounds
delicious, right? We hope so, because if not,
you didn’t die for much - because anyone who
eats the chocolate from SCP-743 is doomed to be
eaten by the millions of flying ant creatures
within. You’ll die screaming, surrounded by
horrific buzzing and feeling a million tiny
legs crawling all over your body. How lovely.
Now, picture an ocean. A vast, roiling ocean,
whipped to and fro by nautical winds. Maybe
this comforts you, or maybe it terrifies you,
because you’ve got Thalassophobia: The fear of
the sea. This is an incredibly popular fear,
because let’s be real, there are a lot
of really scary things under the sea.
Terrifying things you’ll never forget. Or
maybe... Things you’ll definitely forget,
like SCP-3000, Anantashesha. This astronomically
large eel produces amnestics which lull its
victims into a false sense of security before
devouring them. And hell, if the ocean itself
is that terrifying to you, maybe being eaten by
a massive eel god would be a reprieve for you.
Let’s get back out of the water and onto land,
where all kinds of things are slithering. If that
makes you nervous, you might have Ophidiophobia:
The fear of snakes. And if you do, you’re
going to be mortally terrified of SCP-5430,
an Eastern garter Snake that has even greater
locomotive abilities than the average snake,
because it has 48 legs, connected by thaumaturgic
means. It’s essentially the snake equivalent of a
centipede. We don’t even have Ophidiophobia,
and that’s a pretty terrifying thought to us!
But maybe we need to think a little bigger. Or
maybe, a lot bigger. If that sentiment makes you
feel a little nervous, though, you may suffer from
Megalophobia: The fear of large things. There are
many large and terrifying SCPs in this world, but
few are quite as dizzyingly massive as SCP-2317-K,
also known as the Devourer of Worlds.
Just how big is this very hungry boy,
locked away behind the door to another
world? According to our best estimates,
it’s a little over 200 kilometers tall,
roughly equivalent to 451 Empire State
Buildings stacked on top of each other.
Jeez, that makes us feel a little dizzy.
Let’s stop thinking about that, and instead
consider the most frightening thing of all:
Spooky, scary skeletons. Skelephobia: The fear
of skeletons. And for those afraid of skeletons,
SCP-3114 would be an elementally terrifying
entity to encounter. This living skeleton
actually hates being a skeleton, so much so that
if it encounters a human being who does have skin,
it tears the skin off in a jealous rage
and wears it like a costume. So if you
do have Skelephobia, you’d be lucky to
encounter SCP-3114 when it’s wearing
a tasteful human skin outfit. Then I’m
sure it wouldn’t be terrifying at all.
Okay, okay, it’s no secret that we sometimes like
to be funny here on SCP Explained. Much like Dr.
Bright, we use humor as a coping mechanism.
We’re happy to be a little clownish now and
then. That wouldn’t be so chill for people who
suffer from Coulrophobia: The fear of clowns.
And for those terrified of clowns, we know one
show you definitely shouldn’t watch: SCP-993,
Bobble the Clown. This jolly cartoon nightmare is
a clown that loves to teach kids the tools of his
trade, like breaking and entering, murder,
cannibalism, and arson, just to name a few.
If you’re afraid of clowns and you encountered
this show as a kid, you’d be traumatized for
life. Thankfully, though, if you encounter it as
an adult, you’ll just pass out. Small mercies, eh?
Now, some phobias truly can wreck your life.
They can make you afraid of something so common,
so ubiquitous, it makes you wonder how you
can even function. One example is Heliophobia:
The fear of the sun. However, we’d all be sharing
this phobia if SCP-001, When Day Breaks, came to
pass. Simply being exposed to the sunlight would
cause you to melt into a deranged blob. However,
if this ever happened, people suffering from
Heliophobia may actually be the most likely to
survive - Because they’ve already spent their
life building strategies to help them avoid
the piercing gaze of the sun. So maybe keep
a Heliophobe in your life, just to be safe.
Some phobias are, thankfully, a
lot easier for you to avoid. Take,
for example, Coasterphobia: The fear of
rollercoasters. If you have this problem,
just don’t go on a rollercoaster, but
especially not SCP-2183, also known,
ominously, as “The Ride Never Ends.” If you end up
on this ride, you’ll be hurtling through the sky,
screaming in terror, forever. Not fun
for anyone, least of all Coasterphobes.
But maybe rollercoasters don’t make you
nervous. Maybe being watched makes you
nervous. Maybe the idea that there could be a
pair of mysterious eyes boring into you right
now makes your skin crawl. If this is true,
you may have Scoptophobia: The fear of being
stared at. And if you have Scoptophobia, and
you’re not a furry who’s down ludicrously bad,
then you’d be terrified after downloading the MalO
app, also known as SCP-1471. If you download the
app, you’ll be stalked by the skull-faced MalO,
which will stare at you from all your favorite
places. That’ll get your heart rate up, one
way or another. I’ll say no more on that.
Hey, is it getting hot in here? Can you smell
smoke? Can you hear that strange cracking noise? I
certainly hope you don’t have Pyrophobia: The fear
of fire. Fearing fire is honestly pretty natural,
given it can burn you to death, especially if
you’re a liar who’s trapped inside SCP-2128,
a terrifying device known as The Liars Cradle.
If ever you’re locked inside its deadly furnace,
you better choose your words carefully,
or the Cradle will detect your mistruth
and incinerate you. And wouldn’t it suck
to be terrified and agonized as you die?
But perhaps you don’t fear fire; you just fear
ladies that are smoking hot. This means you have
Caligynephobia: The fear of beautiful women. Yes,
it is real. And if you suffer from this phobia,
then you’d be terrified of SCP-056, also
known as A Beautiful Person. The ideal form
of this conceited entity is famous actor Scarlet
Johansson, so if you’re afraid of beautiful women,
then this entity will horrify you to
your core. They’re just a real jerk, too.
What if the early 2010s were just an absolute
nightmare for you, because there were zombies
everywhere. Movies, TV shows, Halloween costumes,
zombie walks, and more merchandise than you shake
Negan’s baseball bat, Lucille, at. This probably
means you have Kinemortophobia: The fear of
zombies. And if that is the case, stay the hell
away from victims of SCP-008. This lethal and
contagious pathogen creates mindless and extremely
aggressive zombies whose only purpose is to spread
their disease to others, adding additional members
to their teeming, mindless horde. So if that’s not
your thing, either keep your distance, or make
sure you have some SCP-500 pills close to hand.
Next, we have another ubiquitous nightmare -
Hydrophobia: The fear of water. It’s everywhere,
and you literally need it to survive, so it’s
a bummer to be petrified by it. Though at least
with SCP-1128, the Aquatic Horror, you’ll have a
very good reason to be afraid of water. After all,
if you see a picture, or get a comprehensive
description of this massive underwater monster,
no body of water is safe. From bathtubs
to cups to swimming pools to puddles,
the horror will stalk you
relentlessly, and eat you alive.
And now, from big horrors, to tiny one.
Microphobia: The fear of small things.
There’s a joke I’d like to make here, but then
we wouldn’t make any money on this video. Anyway,
for anyone paranoid about puny perils, I
bet it’s a nightmare to encounter SCP-165,
the creeping, hungry sands of Tule. Because
while it may look like a pile of sand,
it’s actually a giant pile of almost
microscopic, flesh-eating mites. Sleep tight!
Oh, was that a thunder crack I just heard?
I hope nobody here suffers from Astraphobia:
The fear of storms. Though I think we’d
all be afraid of storms if we had a run-in
with SCP-3280, After The Storm. This is an
extremely dangerous blob of living water,
which is able to incorporate even more
water into its mass. Its favorite hobby
is crawling into your body, stealing
all your water, then bursting out,
leaving you dead. And why do storms make it even
more dangerous? Because it gives the creature a
heavy supply of water. And if this thing ever gets
into the water cycle, we’re probably all doomed.
Let’s move from existential threats to the
threat of murder most fowl - and that’s fowl
with a W. We’re talking about Alektorophobia:
The fear of chickens. Of course, the average
chicken probably couldn’t kill you - at least
not without considerable prep time - but killing
you is incredibly easy for the abominable
chicken-human hybrids known as SCP-3199,
Humans, Refuted. These horrific creations
of a mad evolutionary scientist would strike
fear into anyone, but especially someone
predisposed to fear chicken-like beings.
But what if we took a fear of an animal that could
even kill you without any anomalous influence. A
phobia like Cynophobia: The fear of dogs. And
that fear would only be made worse by a run in
with the ominous SCP-023, also known as Black
Shuck. If you see this terrifying furry beast,
then it means you’re going to die soon. This
is one dog you really can’t call a good boy.
But hey, we’re fair and balanced here
at SCP Explained. That’s why we’re also
including Elurophobia: The fear of cats. And
if you are afraid of cats, then you might be
one of the few people who survive a run in with
SCP-247, ironically dubbed “A Harmless Kitten.”
This is a lie, because this innocent-looking
little cat is actually a highly aggressive,
fully-grown tiger that we just happen to
perceive as a cute, little kitten. Being
afraid of it despite its adorable disguise
is probably the best way to not get mauled.
Now, let’s go from furry to slimy.
That’s right, it’s Batrachophobia:
The fear of amphibians. Frogs, toads, newts.
If it can traverse both water and land,
you’re afraid of it. That’s why, despite
her good-hearted nature, you’d probably
have a heart attack if you ran into SCP-811, the
Swamp Woman. She’s not mean, but she is green,
and she does excrete dangerous acidic mucus.
If you’re afraid of frogs, seeing this huge,
humanoid, frog-like entity would be an excellent
way to ruin your latest pair of tighty whities.
Maybe you’re fine with frogs, though,
but would absolutely die on the spot
if you were faced with a lizard. That
means you’ve probably got Herpetophobia:
The fear of reptiles. The worst thing you
could possibly run into is extremely obvious
here - SCP-682, the legendary, infamous
Hard to Destroy Reptile. There are some
scary lizards out there, but none quite as
scary as this, because it hates all life,
including you, and probably enjoys the fact
that you fear it. Though for what it’s worth,
we think being utterly terrified of running
into this reptile is a very rational fear.
Now, for a slightly more abstract terror:
Autophobia: The fear of being alone. How do
you feel about isolation? Of being separated from
all your friends and family, nobody to hear you,
nobody to help you. Alone, alone, alone. If you
can feel your chest tightening at these words,
not only do you probably have Autophobia, it’d
be your absolute worst nightmare to be trapped
in SCP-3001, the Red Reality, where poor
Dr. Scranton was forced to spend the rest of
eternity. You’re beyond the help of everyone
here, even reality itself. In other words,
it’s a nasty, nasty place to
be, no matter what you fear.
And finally, perhaps the most irrational real
phobia in this video - It’s Bibliophobia:
The fear of books. Typically, books cannot
hurt you, unless you get a paper cut or one
falls on you off a shelf. There are, however,
notable exceptions. Perhaps the most terrifying
of all is SCP-140, a cursed tome known as
An Incomplete Chronicle, or A Chronicle of
the Daevas. Any time this book is exposed to
human blood, it expands and rewrites itself,
bringing the nightmarish Daevite Empire closer
to ruling the world as it is today. In this and
only this very specific instance, the
Bibliophobia is extremely justified.
And there you have it, folks, we’re sorry for
giving you a mild to moderate case of the heebie
jeebies. Which of these phobias apply to you?
And do you think there are any important ones
we missed? Let us know down in the comments.
And of course, remember to subscribe and ring
the bell to turn on notifications, or all of
your worst nightmares will become reality.
Now go check out “What's the Scariest SCP?”
and “25 Most Frightening SCP” for
more gateways to a world of terror!